last time that i saw you was about three
years ago and i think it's fair to say
we both considered ourselves liberals or
democrats or something like that that's
why i wanted to have you on because i
thought oh here's someone sort of on my
team who's frustrated with some of the
stuff that i'm frustrated with
flash forward three years
where are you at in your little
political journey before we fully get
into the book and everything else
as usual still having trouble with
labels i mean i wrote an essay called
why i am not a progressive
so i'm definitely not a progressive i
can't accept that label anymore i
changed my party affiliation in april
from democrat to no party preference
which is what we call independence in
california
i
you know i wrote i have two books out
about one last year one this year
apocalypse never in san francisco were
you know i wrote them in part because i
just wanted to sort of articulate what i
believe you know based on reading the
evidence and what my views are because i
think labels are so inadequate
i think some people um some progressives
will call me you know conservative or
right-wing lunatic of course
um
you know uh i some a lot of people i
think call me a moderate the huffington
post quoted me as a moderate
um you know as usual as you won't be
surprised to hear i mean there's some
views i have that i think would be
better categorized as liberal than
conservative and some views that would
be better categorized as conservative
and i think there's some things that are
not easy to categorize
you know i should note for the record
that i actually still am registered as a
democrat in cali but it's a calculated
move because i wanted to be able to vote
in the primaries so that i could vote
for believe it or not for biden in the
primaries so that i could stop bernie so
that that tells you how that sort of
tells you how politics has become so
crazy and the system is so nuts that you
stay in a party to vote against the guy
you're trying to stop the most you know
yeah
yeah for sure i mean and obviously the
state level now we have a you know an
open primary so that you can vote for um
you know you can have two republicans or
two democrats or two independents in the
runoff so but yeah i just honestly
i i changed my party affiliation because
i just don't feel like it's i just
couldn't live with my conscience to be a
democrat anymore after working on the
new book i just felt like it's just
i i have questions about even i mean i'm
sticking with california i'm going to
fight to save california like you but um
i feel like i'm living in like apartheid
south africa or something i just feel
like i'm living in a place that's not
moral
and and i feel really bad and angry
about that and so
yeah um we don't want to move but it is
it's a this is a pretty this state is
pretty terrible i'm on a lot of levels
yeah let's let's sit with that for a
little bit because as you know i fought
really really hard for this recall i
basically was campaigning with larry
elder the results of this thing were a
disaster
now newsom has you know codified mail-in
ballots basically forever we have one
party rule nothing's working which is so
much of what your new book's about
yeah do you have any hope here like i am
really troubling i'm just having trouble
seeing the hope if i could see some hope
i'd be like yeah i could still stay and
fight but i just don't see that glimmer
i don't see that star in the distance
anymore
yeah i mean i it's dark right now right
and that but i think the darkness is
also means that we just can't see things
and so we should be humble too about our
own inability to to view what might be
out there
you know i will say i think that the
election heavily if you believe the
polling i think it did heavily turn on
the coveted response
um and i think most people in california
and i don't know you and i might not
agree on this but you know i think most
california supported the status quo view
of kovid i wrote i tweeted something
that i think now is overly pessimistic
about how people voted for the status
quo i don't necessarily think that's
true
you know we have polling data that also
shows high levels 75 70 you know 80
support for basically i think the things
the common sense things that i think you
and i will agree that we need to do
about the open air drug scenes what we
euthanistically call homeless
encampments
so i do think there is public support
for a lot of the stuff that we need to
change but yeah i mean we have uh
you know i think we have a leadership
challenge um i uh surprised myself and i
did feel like i needed to endorse
somebody i ended up endorsing kevin
faulconer in the recall i in general i
don't believe in recalls because i do
think you should give the guy the four
years but in this case i thought the
situation on the streets was so extreme
that it merited the recall so i did
endorse the recall and i endorsed kevin
faulconer and
yeah and then i defended you may have
seen i defended um larry elder against
the unconscionable attacks by you know
the
racist antifa woman or i don't know if
she's antifa so don't sue me but the
racist woman in a gorilla mask throwing
an egg at him and just the
unconscionable
uh media coverage by the la times in
particular but really all the state
media
you know clearly
you know
inappropriate i mean i i sort of
flabbergasted still by how terrible and
biased the media coverage was but
yeah i mean i uh with the book and
certainly in a movement that we're
building we have a coalition of groups
including parents of kids killed by
fentanyl including parents whose kids
are addicted to fennel and living on the
streets and who want to get their kids
off the street including recovering
addicts we are advocating for a pretty
sweeping set of reforms so
but yeah it's it was discouraging if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell